this is hilarious I was sent a link
yesterday to the David Pakman show on
Yelp now you're probably thinking why is
the david pakman show on Yelp Yelp is a
review website it's usually for
restaurants maybe sometimes for other
types of businesses pest control or
whatever why is it that the david pakman
show is on Yelp
I don't know the answer usually it's was
your food good and did the waitstaff
treat you well all that stuff I had no
idea but there's an entry for the david
pakman show on Yelp in Northampton
Massachusetts which is where the show
started years ago but is of course no
longer based hilariously were listed
under radio stations and television
stations neither of which we are there
were only about ten reviews as of
yesterday I hope that you'll help us add
some hilarious reviews to this and also
add some pictures there are no pictures
as part of our Yelp profile some of the
reviews are surprisingly bad
Jay Jay from Eustace Texas reviewed our
show by saying quote this dude just
wants to criticize America and all its
inhabitants he wants to tell you how bad
it is there if all people in Argentina
think like him it is a perfect reason
why Argentina has one of the most
corrupt and useless excuses for a
country one can imagine he really should
try to clean his own house Argentina
before he goes to another country and
points out someone else's minor issues
that actually sounds a lot like what
Donald Trump recently said about those
four democratic congresswoman a British
should have taken over that piece of s
country during the Falkland Island but
kicking the a Giunta nians took god save
the queen charlie double used review
different just saying good atmosphere
but terrible pizza anyway this is ripe
for hilarity so please check it out
we're linking to the page on our YouTube
clip you can also find our Yelp page by
going to Yelp com search in Northampton
Massachusetts and type in the David
Pakman show
I predict that a week from now we will
have lots of really really funny reviews
from our audience and probably a lot of
negative excuse me negative ones as well